support our managers um on things like
extend contract training an inclusive
leader and
we have some sessions this morning on
value-based recruitment because i think
it's really important that we do recruit
people not only who have the technical
skills knowledge and experience with the
world online with our
needs
we've engaged with around 100 managers
over a number of sessions regarding our
smart ways of working
and we're starting to embed our
integration proposals
um
and we're continuously asking for
feedback from the workforce
and to continuously improve that
employee experience
we recently launched our
survey our second survey of june
and we had a response rate of 43
which is a great engagement score
um we did the last be heard survey in
2019 we have retained
our
presentation of the one to watch
organization
we have great levels of engagement and
against the backdrop of pandemic
this is a really really great
achievement
we know that in the name our workforce
want to feel well led they want to
develop in their careers
and they want to see
their pay for the work that they do
um so we're now in the process of
circulating feedback and showing
importance feedback
and we're
supporting directors and head to service
to um to to do exactly that because as
i've said i think it's really important
that we we capture the feedback and we
certainly act upon some of the things
that they are telling us
so they also want to highlight that we
started our winter planning early
um we booked our fluid vaccination
clinics um
some of our venues and we're encouraging
our staff to stay well and through our
comprehensive campaign will be offered
that we have in place
and we're also looking at ways to
support our staff and through the living
crisis
as that starts to impact further and we
have a proper healthy financial
well-being offer in place
and we're looking at what we can do um
as an organisation to um as i say to
support
our workforce large percentage of which
are also capital residents
um
and i think you know it's really
important that we also support our
traffic residents to
um to stay warm and well especially as i
say as winter is
clinic
okay so let me stop there and uh
thanks angelo
yeah thanks
clearly you've touched on the cost of
living crisis
and i think many people will be going
through a lot of
hardship at this moment in time but it's
going to get a lot worse
and i think
you know
supporting our staff will be critical
throughout this process and uh
you know
people will be wanting a lot of advice
and
i know that we we have welfare rights
offices
clearly
i don't think there's many of those
officers
that we have and we will need to
um
ensuring that
those officers don't get overwhelmed
with the work that they will
need to be doing
that just brought our evidence i think
the
the warm homes
um you know
warning people
if you like and we you know
how we actually develop some of our
buildings to be able to help support
those people in need
you know who can't afford their
electricity over them
that they will come to us and we need to
be
very prepared for that and
so yeah it's supporting our residency
through this crisis
[Music]
[Music]
and as i said a lot of our
employees are also traffic residents
so we we're looking at what the outcome
possible might be and certainly
utilizing the
experience the
talent within the organisation
and they need to to look at those parts
of the organization who potentially may
be impacted the most
to ensure that we've got the right
levels of
capacity and the right levels of skills
the right levels of
ability to provide that support
because it is absolutely i think and the
priority for all
we've been um with services to ensure
that you know people
can kind of live their best lives and
you know have a
responsibility to support that um
absolutely um
[Music]
you know we do
have sufficient um capacity in all of
those areas and i think i think you know
in previous conversations we do have a
pretty comprehensive capsule
they're available
to our workforce but as as we all know
there's always so much more we can do
with all of these things
and i've got three things that's okay
and
the first one is very mundane um the
m365 update you may not know anything
about it personally but
um the only one to attend um i'm just
conscious that it was uh
announced three months ago four months
ago i think
um
as to get the organization looking a bit
more smoothly is there any pressure
being put on those who may not be
attending uh to get her
equipment updated so that this doesn't
drag on for several months in a massive
possible way
yes i think i mean you must be just done
for cookies today usually i do know this
and sessions are usually packed out so
we'll take the feedback on board and i
think absolutely it is one of the um the
absolute priorities for this
organisation to
ensure that we do move to beneath
technology because i think that is a
real good
more of an enabler and to
enable us to continue to to do the work
that we do
remotely and you know
um
[Music]
to help shape a new structure as it's in
the report and deliver it again
the actual details of this i just wanted
if that if we could get any information
on what that entails um because it's
part of all these statements within the
report to help deliver council by
services but how's it going what's
what's the shape of what
difference
okay
there is a really comprehensive business
case that sits behind that piece of work
and so again i'm happy to take that
offline and provide that information to
you and i'll give you a brief um a brief
video of exactly what the intentions are
um with that
wholesale reorganization
and last
have you ever considered
and this really only applies to the
donors at
[Music]
to assist with
uh climate change initiatives within the
council at home just to have a general
we do it in
[Music]
so again i think yes um but it's
probably just not highlighted in the
report thinking the active travel groups
and in other groups i think that there's
a commitment to
to you know this whole agenda to see how
we employees and as individuals can you
know really support that whole
initiative but again i'll send you an
update that the work that's been
progressing
and sort of that and
how we um intend to kind of continue to
bring that to life
[Music]
okay all right we'll move on to agency
spencer quarter one i think that's you
again angela
it is it is with media temperature um so
this is a regular report comes here
every quarter
and it's called one report it covers
april to june this year
and it details how we use an agency for
consultants
and what i will say is that all of the
um spend is
capable of within current staffing
projects
so i think uh my first focus is within
children's services and again i think we
know that they've suspended this area to
fluctuate
it's probably at its highest um this
time we landed two active assignments
um although it's a slight reduction from
the quarterback figure um it still is
symptomatic of the shortages of
social workers
in the profession and we know that it's
not just a traffic problem it's a
national and it's also a mutual problem
and we do know we can to mitigate this
um we've got a rolling recruitment
program
on social media we've got a wide ranging
development offer
and i just want to talk about some of
that um in this forum really so
we do continue to support a number of
initiatives to help us to grow our
assessment to our newly qualified and
social workers
in the first year and that
allows them to have a protected caseload
for example it allows them to have
additional logical supervision
and
we've got 13 newly qualified social
workers in our children's services
and director and we've got eight in
adult services
um we've also got 17 social work student
placements this year and we've got eight
of the address director and we've got um
children's
and we're also
enabling experienced social workers to
train them to become practice educators
so that they can support our students in
the workplace
and allow and support them to complete
their their communication requirements
we've also got a social work degree
apprenticeship in place and
we've had a number of um individuals who
qualified through this route it's a very
small program the staff in children's
athletes
at the moment we've got seven members of
staff on coal part four so we're in our
fourth year of this
and we've got three step-up students as
well and these are 15 more postgraduate
social work training opportunities and
they're due to start their final
placement rules in september
so as you can see there's a lot of
activity going on um across the board in
that
development arena
so
in the data available to us we know that
um
out of the 11 local authorities we
we're all spending pretty much um a lot
of money in this arena and
so whilst the figures appear high to us
and they are high um we're maintaining
in comparison to our statistical
neighbours
i can also update that
directly in children's services now
friday and
again on the table is we want to secure
an agreement password to manchester to
establish what we're calling it a pledge
i think you need movement i think we've
talked about this before
and
and the pledge is about establishing um
race and pay consistent rates and pay
for
agency workers and to reduce the current
variances that that are happening across
the way to manchester
i think there is broader consensus again
it's the right thing to do
and so we are
all meeting um from a hr
collective um
to
start to shape up i guess um working
with our own director for children's
services the conversations i've only
started with jill mcgregor he's our
director of children's here in trafford
um
so it does feel like there is a momentum
again being some pace here in trafford
led by um
children's services
and you know they're also lobbying for
the national pace line for example from
social workers to be in states as well
which i think will help
so as these progressives are people
updated um of course
so i think just moving then on to the
adults directorate and we've seen a
slight increase in spending in this
quarter and again and we're supporting
the adults director in
employment areas so for example um we're
fast tracking um support working
recruitment in ascot house
and
to ensure that we we
don't impose a relies on agency workers
there
and through the learning academy and
building strong connections with schools
and so that's about promoting the
foundations and health and social care
as a qualification as a career
and
[Music]
we
we've got some schools now who
actually undertake health and social
care as a gcse level qualification
and we're also part of an apprenticeship
clients and with
through grace manchester for two new
starters that have been um in our health
and care space and we're holding into
east disneyland so again i'll update you
um
once that has happened
so i think you know there's there's
wrecking programmes of essential
entertainment training courses for all
of our social workers
we've also got our
learning partners strengthening practice
and
they become the second phase of their
large-scale training programme
across all these all areas of early
health and children's social care
and so we're transforming the
facilities as well
and we've got subscriptions to a company
called research and practice and there's
lots of evidence for practice and a host
of online resources available and and
lots of events
so as you can see you know we do
normally have clean traffic
to um support our employees to have a
great experience and to
reduce the reliance on agency workers
but given that it
obviously need is have a resource in
place
we're working collaboratively with our
directors of adult services and our
director of children's services
and hopefully we will finally get to
that place um
of pay rates and hopefully some
less
reliance on agents and workers in this
space
so again
in other directions there's various
situations in agency development
[Music]
is increasing
[Music]
thank you for that very comprehensive
review answer any questions
and
yeah i mean obviously this is a standing
item on the agenda
and rightly so
i think none of us in this room want to
see
you know the level of agency
that we do but
um
i do feel that we're trying to tackle it
because
um
and
you know a lot of the measures that you
use outlined i think
um hopefully will bear
fruit
um but it is
clearly a national
problem uh you know there's a national
shortage of
social workers and
care workers
and
that creates
real difficulties
um
a lot
of stuff are on low ages and get burnt
out as well in terms of the
work that they have to do um
and i think the pressures that they want
is
enormous
uh and i you know i i congratulate those
that
you know
we do empower
you know for me
um
clearly we need to keep this on the
agenda we need to keep these updates of
what we're trying to do i think
uh collaborating with the other
authorities is something that we've
talked about quite a lot and hopefully
we'll get off the ground
at some point so that we you know we're
not competing against each other for
the same stuff basically
um but it is a you know it is a national
problem
that
needs to be sorted out
nationally
help us recruit more social workers and
at the last children young people
scrutiny meetings mentioned that blog
plans for um perhaps a gm wide agency
for social workers i was just wondering
if the plans for those have progressed
at all
i think that's all part of the i suppose
the conversations that are happening at
the moment um
with directors of children's services i
think we have muted that a while for a
while
and yes it's a it's normal the options
um
to switch the dependency tap off um by
having a
a social work dedicated to the region
and so a long day
and i'll get an update on on that and
there's a meeting i think second place
later this month
and
again
we've had lots of meetings and i think
i'm hoping um this time it just feels
slightly different i think there is more
than a lesson gathering behind it and
the movement almost takes place
um because i think you know as counselor
said
on this agenda on this committee um
and
you know despite all of the the real
positive things that we're all doing in
indonesia there is still a national
so so i think you know we've got to do
something different and for sure
thank you
just to say i have no issues at all um
you know what the nation needs is
[Music]
and these are the people that keep this
country going our staff in this council
keep traffic going and i just you know
wish they could be we could reward them
with the pay rises that they actually do
put an end to this concept of
consultancy but yeah i have no issues
keep up the good work let's just hope
that at some point
we get a national government that will
properly fund local authorities who they
can then properly
award our staff that increases they
thoroughly deserve thank you
thanks councillor dream and i can't
argue with the word of that and the
reality for our residents if this
council hasn't got the money to keep
funding these services what happens to
these very very vulnerable people
because there's no the private sector
will stop caring for them if they're not
getting money to do that so i don't
think government are aware of just how
unprecedented some of our most
vulnerable residents are not everybody
can get the care that we deserve
getting care these days is incredibly
difficult finding the stuff to deliver
the care is getting harder and harder
and particularly sharpened
so i do think everything you've said
that we've agreed with more council
agreement
does anybody else have any questions on
this item
now in that case then we'll move on to a
good news story that cadet lee
does
okay thank you good afternoon so yes
this is a positive story so you know
within the council we've had a publicly
special
public duties policy for many many years
and over the years we've added more
opportunities to that as things moved
and changed so basically the policy
gives um provision to start to take paid
leave from different public duties and
in more recent years we've added in the
offer around um
policing um duties and other armed
forces support
and we have within traffic on a really
proud history of working with the armed
forces and that sort of goes through the
arms and forces covenant which we've had
in place for years
um and in 2019 we submitted for and we
were successful in the um
defense and for recognition scheme gold
award we've had this little previously
and then we improved our offer and our
support and we went to gold award um
which is the highest level so we're
really really proud of that achievement
but we want to sustain that obviously we
want to keep the commitment going and so
we're applying for the award in 2023 and
as part of that to make sure we're
keeping you up to date with the criteria
you want to add in this additional
provision
um so basically it's having paid leave
for employers who volunteer as cadet
leaders
so you know we talked about volunteering
angela mentioned earlier in staff have a
lot of staff who are very public-minded
means the nature of what they do with a
role but also in terms of what they do
outside of work as well
and potentially do provide a really
valuable role working with young people
they help train cadets and they helped
to run the meetings and providing
activities and put on events
and so in recognition and their
contribution we are proposing to offer
10 days
however what we'll do is
we haven't really considered that in the
past and so it could be sort of a win
for the community with the pencil as
well okay and i will finish then thank
you
any questions on this item
well i propose that we welcome this new
initiative and hopefully we see some
people come forward who are enthused by
this thank you
back to angela of course for the
exemptions to the sickness policy
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much good afternoon
everyone
okay so for um quarter two the last
quarter which is april to june 22
there were seven exception requests to
one of occupational
all seven were approved
two of those requests came from our
adults directorate not to mention both
were approved in our children's
directorate we received four and again
born approved and christian resources
one request was received and approved
um
what i can tell you is that what we have
seen is a reduction in the amount of
time the amount the exception request is
full
so it has been in the class where it's
been two or three months most of the
ones that we've received in the last
quarter has been for a reduced period of
time so just for a month
and happily five of those particular
cases of those requests
five of the seven have now been resolved
through the individual return to work so
we've been able to support them
successfully and obviously during that
really difficult period or we've been
able to support them with very
significant long-standing health
conditions and we've supported them
through navigating the pension process
and they've ill health retirements
throughout our very good local
government pension scheme
so there's two that remain outstanding
um both of which were unforeseeable and
we continue to support the individuals
in circumstances
any questions
thank you
thank you
right i am aware that we received
a piece of urgent business which is
building control market rate proposal i
think adrian's going to introduce this
paper
uh thank you chair and uh good evening
councillors so for those of you that
know me i'm
i'm director of growth and regulatory
services um and thank you very much for
taking this additional item uh this
evening
the report concerns market supplements
for the building control team
um so for those of you not familiar with
building control it's slightly unusual
in terms of council functions in that it
is a mix of both traded services and
also statutory functions and so you have
elements
where
the private sector operates um so unlike
a planning application which has to come
to the council you can go and get your
building control application determined
um by a kind of company so they operate
in exactly the same space as the council
and we operate in direct competition
however
the council
has certain statutory responsibilities
um which it has to uphold
and often they're the kind of time
consuming um you know
really quite complicated activities um
and so what's that has led to over a
number of years is that um private
companies have been um very successful
in concentrating on those profitable
areas of activity they don't need to do
any they don't have to do any of the
statutory stuff um and so they've been
quite adept uh
recruiting staff uh primarily from um
local authorities uh and giving them if
you like you know a more attractive
proposition which is a job just focused
on if you like good stuff and less of
the sort of more complicated
activities
um so that's been ongoing for some time
and that's meant that uh for a while now
um
we've had
certain problems with both retention and
recruitment
but added to that um we now have the
advent of the building safety act so the
building safety act uh comes in
partly and i think really is the
consequence of the tragedy at grenfell
tower um and that
shapes up the whole system of
um
looking at the safety of buildings and
we have a new building safety regulator
which
is the health and safety executive and
that imposes
new obligations new structures
and
it's also a new accountability i suppose
as well in that
some the council indeed anybody
operating uh
under building control has now to uh
meet um a series of standards they could
be audited
and also staff
have to
register and show their competence um
and this is i suppose a little bit of
equivalent of maybe retaking a driving
test or something a little bit like that
whereby you know you may have been
operating for many many years but you
will now have to go through a process of
showing that you are um
you know
good enough to do that now of course you
know that's there for some very very
good reasons
there's lots of welcome
in in all the facts but one of the
consequences is that uh on top of what
i've just described about generally
quite a competitive and difficult
environment
what we're finding is that across local
authorities and
quite a lot of the older staff are
looking at this and thinking
yeah this is this is in effect
obligations that i just don't need at
this point and then maybe moving moving
on to other jobs or
choosing to take time
um
and so
if we are to
retain our staff we need to recognize
some of these pressures um but also
there are some opportunities here as
well um and so in contrast perhaps to
some of the difficult uh discussions
we're just having earlier about you know
council services and restraints on
funding
if the council is able to maintain a
successful team
then it will receive work directly from
the building safety regulator and of
course it can compete
successfully and for wider work as well
so so to that extent it is a slightly
better story because you know we're not
up against some of those you know
limited financial envelopes that we are
here with many other council functions
so as a consequence of all of this as i
say we recognize that we need to
look after our existing staff and also
have
a package
to recruit
more um officers as well
so as part of that we are currently
reviewing uh salaries for the control
team to make sure that they are um
uh you know on a par with others across
greater manchester and at least perhaps
with the touching distance of the
private sector
um
and
over
some time now we've had market
supplements
and
that has done some of that job but uh
the request is that we retain those
marketing supplements because clearly if
we are
um
moving up the base
but if we take away market supplement
that rather negates the whole point of
it so we need to maintain those
supplements in order to ensure that we
get the general uplift
across the piece um so
i gather that that has been something
that other services have put before this
committee so
uh consequently that's the same request
here is that we maintain those
supplements and review them i sat down
in the report
thank you
thank you
no issues with the paper fully supported
um used to be an area of mine um of
interest when i was on the executive i
know exactly where the
agent's coming from on this
and it's just another example isn't it
of where
you know we used to be okay of building
controls it all used to come through the
local authority then someone was a good
idea to let private
enterprise better
who picks up the work the local
authority who doesn't get paid for that
local property yeah you've got my
support hope
for this girl with it
thank you for that passionate
responsibility
yeah i mean i i absolutely agreed with
mike
on this one
it is such an important area building
control
safety really and i think
um you you only need to look at you know
tragedy
where nobody took any kind of
responsibility
um
due to the relaxation of regulation
and all of that
and and i think
um
a question that i would like to
ask is
that building regulatory body
you you mentioned everything that
um work may come our way will they
actually pay us
thanks um i actually agree with you
council bring situations on television
it's either one or the other and the uh
current system doesn't work individually
directly to what happened down in london
so and just a question on the that's my
first question about um
benchmarking against here um
you don't really understand where our
current this is current salaries sit
within the western councils
um
it it it's a mixed picture but certainly
our um
uh
where where we are with most of our
bands is that we are
um now below where the rest of great
manchester is i mean we have to
you know
have to become careful of trying to
almost get into a sort of you know arms
race on on this because
the probably one of the big issues is
that there is there's not enough skilled
people overall
and there are separate measures which
are not really subject to this report to
try and recruit more people which is
very much
something else that needs to happen but
the intention is to at least make make
sure that we are
um you know we're on our part
we're reasonable and we're not making
the money that's that's nice
so that leads on to the second one um
uh obviously there's a shortage exactly
from a higher profession but salaries
are just going up and up and up
um no no issue with the supplements is
needed but um are you guys coming back
in frequent time
um i hope not but i can't you know
there's reference within the report that
this is quite a dynamic situation and we
don't yet know
quite how this is all going to roll out
and we'll probably know more as as we
get closer to you know the effective
date um
we are um labc which is the
unpredictable organization for uh local
authority building control
have got a program where they're hoping
to bring in uh degree apprentices into
great manchester um and uh the hope
might be that each authority will
supplement that as well and that's
long-term discussion but um but yes
it's difficult because we don't we don't
yet know we're dealing with quite a bit
of the industry we don't fully know all
the implications
thank you any further questions or
comments for
[Music]
[Music]
very good
thank you